yeah i mean you just you could just tell
you were having more and more fun
i remember the the audience even like
even
during the whole run of all the uh the
um the movies
i remember forcing my mom well i didn't
force my mom she loved horror movies and
got me to watch
horror movies with her when i was eight
so that's why i'm kind of [ __ ] up
but um we're watching uh the one where i
believe it's dream warriors
and i remember somebody in the audience
just jumped up and goes
that's freddy's mama
helena krueger and i was i remember
going wow
man people are excited about this movie
still
well you know there's a great happy
accident
and and i'm sure it's happened to you
with some cult films
video for me would have been dvd for you
michael
but i came of my career came of age
during the video revolution so i had hit
movies in the theaters
and then they became hip hip hip films
again when they came out in video to a
whole other audience
yep but i had that times eight
and that's not counting the tv series
and not only do i have that
times eight but then i have it again
with dvd
and blu-ray and cable and
and marathons on cable so you get a new
generation
yeah i'm on my third generation of fans
see what you're saying is you're rich
the movie had a 20-year run it was 84
84-94
and then 10 years went away and then we
did freddie versus jason
and that revived that revived it again
for a new generation so we
actually had a 20-year run
eight movies a television series jesus
man
and dvd and videos and ever and then the
videos became the making of
and then the dvs became blu-ray you know
and
uh and and they became more
sophisticated
now people aren't doing that anymore but
now people i i was i wasn't looking
like on the subset of menus on a
streaming app the other day
and i couldn't believe it it was there
was like a robert england section
you know of just horror movies you know
what how cool is that i've done you know
in europe